number five
[Music]
it's been said that Nostalgia ain't what
it used to be
but there is a time and a place we all
love to look back on and that is the 80s
it was a decade when what we wore was
big bold and not for everyone
yo
the colors my mind was blown
time when success was defined by excess
power glamor greed is good
men were peacocks
you could wear anything it was enormous
fun
with all these looks to choose from it
is our mission to narrow them down to
10. the streetwear that defined the
decade but only one will be the best of
the best
[Music]
we're gonna start with a bang
the unlikely story of an item that went
from British aristocracy to become one
of the signature looks of hip-hop let's
tip our caps to number 10.
[Music]
foreign
not only marched to A Different Drummer
it marched to a whole new rhythm
hip-hop
and the crown and Glory of hip-hop
fashion is our number 10. party don't
start till I walk
Kangal hat
Tangles was
and if you had a Kango you had a little
juice because you had a Kango
did I wear a Kangol hat yes
the Kangol hat became the defining look
of 80s hip-hop and like so many great
stories ours begins in high school
but LaGuardia high isn't just any High
School
it was made famous in a movie and TV
show
let me stop right there let me tell you
about how I got into rapping
we in a classroom we got a substitute
teacher he starts banging on the table
him and a few other dudes you know and
he starts rapping
and I was like I need to know how to do
this so that night I went home and
started writing a rap
well I walked into the office what did I
see oh well I'll say
well sitting in our chair whipping on
white gown she said Dana Dane would you
please lay down the actual day that I
can remember us becoming the Kango crew
was a day called hat and tie day
you come in you wear any type of hat you
want and you wear a tie and you wear an
incredible outfit
so we decided we were going to wear
tangles that's when we became the Kango
crew what we had in common was we like
to dress fresh and that's what they
called it fresh how you rock your hat
man how sporty fresh ones
dressing fresh in the 80s was a
statement I am somebody and I feel good
about myself
and feeling fresh was dressing like
conservative golfers
we saw cats in the golf course with the
kangos and thought hey that's a cool
look right there
Tangles started making Berets in the UK
in 1938.
and went on to make headwear for
generals princesses and yes golfers
rappers like Dana Dane introduced Kangol
to the street we just repurposed what
was around us that's what hip-hop was
built from
but it's the Kangol bucket hat that
becomes the signature look of 80s
hip-hop
it was definitely organic word of mouth
when I was little I saw a wool
that red kangel is amazing I gotta get
one
[Music]
Tangles took off like wildfire as 80s
hip-hop blazed up the charts
[Music]
when LL Cool J came on he had no shirt
but he had on the Kango men would just
focus on the hat I was focusing on the
chest
we like to say about hip-hop we didn't
invent anything but we created
everything
when you put that candle on you felt
like the baddest on the planet
[Music]
now how on Earth did we arrive at our
top ten good question
a panel of eight experts rank the items
from ten to one considering two factors
80s wow their importance at the time and
impact their legacy today
the panel's mission to discover the most
vital street wear fashion of the decade
the 80s was also the decade when the
fashion police had trouble tracking many
moving violations of good taste and when
it comes to movement our number nine
revolves around a guy who inspired an
entire sport or Defying Gravity was the
easy part
[Music]
in the mid-1970s The Skateboarding craze
took off among Southern California's
rebellious youth
in the early 80s those Rebels were
joined by a new recruit who would change
their game I was a teenager when I
really got into skating most heavily and
had a pretty good run of success
I was making a living doing what I loved
I was traveling the world
[Music]
foreign
Hawk knew you had to have the right
shoes in order to ride those Urban waves
I saw an advertisement in the skate
magazine and I'll never forget I thought
there's a shoe made for skateboarding I
have to have it
[Music]
Vans shoes in the 80s were the skate
shoes
[Music]
my dad drove me to the van store it was
like a half hour away from our house
I knew right when I put on my first pair
of Vans and stood on a skateboard that
that was the shoe
were perfect for skaters
special thing about the soul it was a
waffle design that gripped the boards
they felt bored better
Tony do that Ollie dude at Del Mar I'm
on it's so sick
they identified me as a skater probably
most importantly
I could feel that it was sticking to my
board and they actually do work on a
skateboard
[Music]
s off
and get another Boost from a stoner
classic that was my skull
so wasted
[Applause]
[Music]
but in the mid 80s The Fortunes of
skateboarding and vans are set to take a
dive
the sign reads no skateboarding you
won't find skateboarders here on the
Loring Greenway where skateboarding is
prohibited
[Music]
but the 80s had a way of transforming
Rebellion into merchandise
today Vans is a four billion dollar
company
and Tony Hawk well four decades later
he's still riding vans
when I skate now I'm wearing the exact
same model shoes that I skated in when I
was 14.
[Music]
pretty hot that was mental
we've gathered here today to count down
the top 10 streetwear Fashions of the
1980s and I'm proud to say that number
eight was inspired by one of my
Outsiders co-stars
[Applause]
[Music]
all the good sunglasses all of them come
out of the 80s
in the early 1980s Ray-Ban is a brand on
the way down so they decide to get busy
getting noticed
[Music]
Tom Cruise in Risky Business with you
know the famous poster
called product placement the idea is
just to get a star to wear your product
and after Tom Cruise turns Ray-Ban
Wayfarers into a Smash Hit the company
focuses on another of its most iconic
brands
foreign
[Music]
they're called aviators these are things
Flyboys would use to fight glare when
they're flying planes
aviators are really just standard
military issue until
Tom Cruise relaunches these iconic
sunglasses
[Applause]
aviator sunglasses are this innately
All-American clean-cut heroic movie star
look
it's no wonder they took off
the movie star coupled with Ray-Ban
aviators captures the mood of the times
as another movie star leads the charge
for the U.S to reclaim its military
swagger
You Ain't Seen Nothing Yet
Ronald Reagan was really trying to
expand the military at that time let's
go
I'm sure they were really glad when that
movie came out because it's basically a
long patriotic music video that all
appealed very much in Reagan's America
[Music]
Aviator just latched onto that
everybody had them
one year after
the box office Ray-Ban sales hit an
all-time high of 1.2 billion dollars
and thanks to some Maverick product
placement aviators are as popular today
as they've ever been
I hope that Tom Cruise had stock in
Ray-Bans that's all I'm saying
so far we have the Kangol hat at number
10. the van shoe at number nine and
Ray-Ban at number eight but our number
seven is an item invented in the 50s
that shaped a fashion craze in the 80s
it was incredibly flexible and movable
it was awesome
[Music]
turn up your television okay because
you're not going to believe what you're
about to hear would you please join with
me and welcome Twisted Sister
constantly asked what I missed the most
about the 80s and I always say spandex
because it was so liberating
in 1984 Twisted Sister hit the big time
by turning traditionally Macho heavy
metal on its head and stretching into a
miracle fabric that would cover the 80s
in athletic and not so athletic Glory
[Music]
I can not think of one place that I wore
my Spandex that I ever regretted it I
looked cool
spandex was comfortable and everything
was clear as a belt there were no
secrets
I found out from some fans from back in
the earliest days of the band that they
said did you know that we could see your
junk
and someone who had seen it all before
was Dee's main squeeze I've really got
to give credit to my wife Suzette for
introducing me and the band to Spandex
and that all started with her walking to
the club one night wearing a top she
knew I liked only to find me on stage
wearing the same top and when she asked
me why I was wearing the same top I said
I told you I loved your top you didn't
think I meant on you did you
at that point he said I'm not gonna have
my boyfriend wearing my clothes anymore
and started making Twisted Sister's
outfits as she did for the whole time
I lost my 18 hour girl
what I'll cut it on
bizarrely spandex emerged from a lab in
Nazi Germany it was then refined by
Dupont chemicals and given the trade
name Lycra
Spandex and Lycra are the same thing but
it's like Kleenex and tissue
what what you will
[Music]
from being the outfit of choice for
wrestlers and rock stars to becoming
mainstream fashion are you ready to do
the workout
after breaking her ankle on the set of
The China Syndrome Jane Fonda turns to
aerobics to help with her recovery
the workout video becomes the
best-selling VHS of all time and
millions of
humans ditched their polyester for
spandex
it was a Cornerstone of fashion design
[Music]
fall 1987 Donna Karen sum it up
stretch where would Donna Karen be
without spandex where would Gianni
Versace be without spandex
[Music]
spandex made Clues easier for women
it became so popular because it was so
accessible
and it came in different colors I had
some hot pink spandex and white ones I
look like a walking burrito I did not
care because I had on my Spandex
there's never a bad time for spandex
[Music]
Counter Culture of the 60s became
over-the-counter culture rock and roll
became corporate and got its own 24 7 TV
channel
sitcoms like Family Ties turned aging
hippies into a punchline even jeans
swapped the word ordinary with designer
creating a product that reinvented
another Revolution get ready for our
number six
[Music]
I thought acid wash didn't was
disgusting because it really was
associated with all the music that was
tacky like Tiffany
got to be with me
[Music]
in the early 1980s sales of traditional
denim are in Decline the industry needs
a radical reboot meet the guy who would
become the Godfather of denim
when we started working in the 80s we
had totally different cons my mission
was to bring the gene to a different
level
culture the idea was to wash the jeans
with bleach and Stones also known as
Stone washing
then
the accident at the factory somebody
forgets to add the water that dilutes
the bleach
[Music]
and we realized that was creating an
effect that was very very interesting
although acid wash is born out of a
blunder it's a very profitable one the
treatment of acid wash was revolutionary
we'd never seen anything like that
before technology helped invent new ways
to wear denim everything that looked old
was New Again
[Music]
within a few years acid wash denim is
everywhere and worn by every celebrity
from Dolly Parton to Andre Agassi
[Music]
I loved it I had my fair share of acid
wash jeans and jackets
and then when they started coming out
with the colored acid wash my mind was
blown
you can totally revive denims as its own
Market within the fashion industry
it wasn't just denim it was acid wash
denim
and love it or loathe it acid wash denim
just won't go away it's
neat fashion always turn a little bit
like a full circle and here we are
Ashland washes back again
acid wash denim joins our top 10 at
number six but as we close in on the
final 580 streetwear Fashions it's time
to seriously pad our numbers
they used to make bras with built-in
shoulder pads that you'd wear under a
shirt or a t-shirt
[Music]
so we've run through some of the major
food groups of 80s fashion Ray-Bans
designer jeans sneakers and of course
our beloved spandex
items
to make it to our top five or in this
case should I say
nine to five
the 80s were a time of Wars both cold
and cultural Ronald Reagan took on the
evil empire and at the same time a
battle of the sexes was raging
and that particular battle wore an
iconic uniform
[Music]
the 80s shoulder pass was the business
shoulder pads and big hair and Bam and
Dynasty
dressing up as Alexis Colby was
fantastic because she had an unlimited
funds she had an unlimited budget to buy
her clothes and her jewels
I like it very nice
much bigger than the office that you
used to have
excellent decorator
and what I know and by the second season
I could call the shots and one of the
shots I called was I had just been in
Paris and Pierre cardan had brought out
the new look of shoulder pads and I
loved it looks rather good doesn't it
yes it does
it's not long before the trend spreads
to South Fork and oozes onto the set of
every glamorous TV show Dynasty started
High fashion a little sooner than we did
and then you know all the women on our
show
you know and boy all of a sudden the
Wardrobe just got to be the star of the
show for several years
is also exciting
excited
[Music]
Dynasty and Dallas glamorized the look
but real women in the workplace also
needed a uniform that meant business
there's a lot of different ways that
shoulder pads trickle down to the
average girl
foreign
would be through films like working girl
I've never worked for somebody who's
younger than me before or for a woman
well there's the first time for
everything
that's not gonna be a problem is it Tess
no good
why don't you pours a cup of coffees and
come on inside I'm like
no sugar
good afternoon do your clothes get you
respect or whistles
[Music]
you dress for success
today I'll be speaking to a clothing
engineer he is John T Malloy the book is
called the woman's dress for success
book
leave it to a man to tell a woman that
she should
take a man to get ahead if a woman wants
to give orders this is what she wears if
a woman wishes to be taken seriously
this is what she wears now clothing
never gets anyone into the boardroom but
the wrong clothing can keep you out
[Music]
what women did in the 80s was basically
do a female version of a male silhouette
business women need to look a certain
way they're attractive feminine clothes
that fit into a business world the
higher the shoulder pad the closer to
God
and that held true to the American
working woman
trying to muscle in into what was male
territory so the bigger the shoulder pad
the easier it was to make space for
women
I think that there were women who were
role models on television and in movies
and I feel the 80s women came into their
own they were fabulous I go or I Stay
where I choose
shoulder pad sits at number five but
with four contenders left in the race
it's still all to play for but what will
be our number one
sneakers that got banned a shirt that
brought you into an exclusive club or a
look ripped off from Colombian drug
lords
so many choices so little time
so we're more than halfway through and
the competition is ugly
sour some of the outfits our number four
is the story of a bunch of guys who saw
both Beauty and cool in the most
unlikely places
[Applause]
Run DMC are the first 80s hip-hop band
to make it big in the charts and they're
about to make streetwear history
when we did our first album
runs brother Russell Simmons was like
you'll need stage wardrobe
but we wanted to be authentic and we
wanted to be real
so our wardrobe is the tracksuits it's
what we wear it's real
[Applause]
in the 80s Run DMC was saying we're just
going to do our own thing we're from the
hood and we're gonna represent the hood
and they wore tracksuits because that's
what they were every day and they wore
it on stage sneakers were also part of
the look and
Brands so much they made a record about
it my
haters walk to concerts
don't hate all the people gave and the
poor got paid and out us because I just
speak I wore my sneakers but I'm not a
sneak
in 1986 My Adidas is a top five hit
sales of the brand soar
Run DMC made Adidas popular
the whole thing is about look and when
you're looking for a certain type of
look Adidas was giving it to you this
mysterious spike in sales causes some
serious head scratching back at Adidas's
headquarters in Germany they couldn't
understand why is it selling like this
and rumor has it was like an intern
you know what I'm saying I was at Adidas
yo dude what you don't know Run DMC made
a hip-hop song about Adidas
what the hell is a Run DMC
so what they did it being the big Mighty
Corporation they are they sent a spy
like the CIA you need to go to New York
and find out what this Run DMC thing is
what is this hip-hop thing
it's a hot July night at a sold-out
Run-DMC show and the Spy marketing exact
Angelo anastacio turns up to see them
play we get to the point where we're
ready to do the Adidas record everyone
says take it off
I'll take off my shoe he says hold it up
I hold up my shoe and his room was like
d what is that and I looked that run and
I said
[Music]
well and we did the record in the whole
place went crazy
all 18 000 people held up their new
sneakers Angelo called back to Adidas in
Germany it's true it's true there is
this thing called Run DMC in this thing
called hip-hop and they made a sneaker
and it's the biggest thing that I ever
saw
after Adidas saw that show we're going
to give you an endorsement deal
is it huh
we didn't understand the language we
couldn't comprehend that I'm gonna get
new Adidas for life
Adidas and Run DMC sign a 1.6 million
dollar endorsement deal the first ever
between a sports brand and a hip-hop
group
thank you
before Run DMC was like a track suit you
wore it to warm up for tennis
and after it was a style Street stable
it wasn't like we sat there and said
we're gonna be pioneers of marketing and
commercialization we don't toss us into
plan we're down forever and we won't be
happy it was crazy
and we didn't make that record to get
money from Adidas or nothing we just
made it because it was like I said this
is what all the youth wear and it was
like our tribute
now there are some 80s streetwear
fashions that are better left in the
dust spin of History uh parachute pants
anyone but coming up three must wear
Essentials
so let's talk 80s Hollywood
High Concepts ruled the TV Airwaves who
can forget NBC's out or the A-Team or
as much as we try Manimal
back in the day one of the smart guys at
the same network bought another show
idea that had been delivered to him on a
cocktail napkin
it would turn into our number three
that very high concept
MTV cops
[Music]
September 16 1984. the first episode of
an entirely new kind of TV show airs
it fuses The Narrative rhythms of a cop
drama
free Miami Vice
what the designer looks and execution of
a music video
an alluring mixture that's going to
launch a Sleek kind of men's fashion
the Miami Vice look was very much based
on what the two main characters Crockett
and tubs would wear which were suits
with a T-shirt and then loafers but with
no socks which was a revolution this is
me this is where are your socks uh
I don't appear anymore I love that show
so much I took every opportunity I could
to wear loafers without socks
Miami Vice is one of the biggest TV cop
shows of the 80s he plays Detective
Sonny Crockett on Miami Vice please
welcome Don Johnson
Don Johnson oh he could wear a linen
suit like nobody's business this is the
the hottest show I guess on television
here you are on the cover of Us magazine
uh yeah Johnson here you are on the
cover of Rolling Stone with your buddy
Philip Michael Thomas anything to look
cool on him put a shower curtain on it
just because you were homicide doesn't
mean you have to dress like a corpse
look at this guy Alpha 106.18 camera
Mark show co-creator Michael Mann and
his costume team had to keep up with all
these costume changes as many as eight
per episode
I don't think viewers realize that
Crockett and tubs were wearing something
that might be worn by the kind of guys
that they were actually trying to
apprehend
in the early 80s Colombian drug lords
flood Miami with cash from cocaine
on the one hand we're taking a little
bit of license there but on the other
hand these guys that we're after live
that way so in order to get them you
gotta be like one of them
at its height Miami Vice is watched by
up to up to 22
mid bull
many of whom then went out shopping
we did make a huge impact culturally so
once you started seeing how popular the
show was you started seeing the fashion
replicated this year tradition is out
and Miami Vice is in this outfit would
run you about 670 dollars
can you imagine how much it would be if
you
had to buy socks too
Don Johnson's outfit was copied by a lot
a lot of people
if he wore something on that Friday the
next week you saw 15 guys walking down
the street with the same suit
when the stars showed up the crowd went
crazy
John Johnson smiled at you yeah is that
good oh God I touched on Johnson
[Applause]
if I'm perfect honest at that time if I
had to be a white man I'd have been Don
Johnson
[Music]
the Miami Vice designer outfit literally
Wows the 80s
and some cool dudes continue to be
influenced by it today
come on I think the Miami Vice look
could have been a little further up the
chart I mean it was the first time a TV
series was designed to look and feel a
certain way but number two may have the
simplest most powerful brand of all time
a man on a horse
wielding a mallet
[Music]
I think I offer a value to the consumer
I'm offering a product that is beautiful
and the best that I can possibly make
Ralph Lauren started out as Ralph
liebshitz and one of his first jobs was
working at Brooks Brothers and what he
saw there was the iconic quality of the
button-down shirt so when he started
Ralph Lauren he looked at what could
people wear that would make them feel
part of the club the way the Brooks
Brothers customer felt
he did an amazing thing I think he
realized his own dream he wanted this
air of what would be I guess American
aristocracy
from his humble beginning selling ties
in the 60s by the mid 80s Ralph Lauren
had hit the big time and in the spring
of 1986 he opens his first complete
lifestyle store in New York there was a
building at 72nd and Madison Avenue
called the Rhinelander mansion and
[Music]
all of his Gothic details would
represent the clubbiness that is close
suggested
the interior had old leather couches
plaid blankets there was a Library part
of his dream was to live the fantasy to
meet his own aspirations
and all this aspiration required was to
wear a simple shirt
Ralph Lauren's polo shirt is a classic
and belongs to this very short list of
very established iconic garments and
that is definitely one of them
I think of Ralph Lauren as the ultimate
dresser of preppy people and preppiness
was a huge phenomenon in the 80s
so if you were distinguishing yourself
as preppy you had to have a polo shirt
Lauren was inspired by Lewis Lacy an
anglo-argentine Polo player of the 1920s
you Associated it with class
you saw Prince Charles playing Poland
you saw all of those men down in
Venezuela on their horses playing Polo
you could be a part of that group or
associated with that group just by
wearing that shirt
aspect of the 80s
the 80s was really show and tell
foreign
that price point made it accessible
enough that if you had the shirt you
could be part of the brand
you were buying the Ralph Lauren vision
of the world the polo shirt was a
bestseller in the aspirational 80s and
led to the global success of Lauren's
Vision success that paid a big dividend
it took Ralph Lauren three decades to
build his two and a half billion dollar
company but it will likely take him just
one day to earn a half billion dollars
selling a piece of it
[Music]
and his family could put in the bank
about 450 million dollars after this
offering it's not a bad piece of loose
change I always loved his
very influential it was very thought
it was very distinctive it was a very
clear look that's why it's still here
Ralph Lauren was one of the first
designers to understand that fashion
could be lifestyle
everything about the Ralph Lauren world
was in that one shirt
now we've celebrated branding logos and
Footwear and our ranking of 80s
streetwear when we come back our number
one an item that truly takes off into
Legend
[Music]
we've seen nine of the street Street
professions that Define a decade from
Fashions born on the street to styles
from Paris
but nine contenders have fallen
and there can only be one number one
80s fashion often revolved around huge
personalities from Tony Hawk and vans to
Joan Collins and shoulder pads to Ralph
Lauren and Polo but now a full court
press to are number one inspired by my
favorite athlete of all time the goat
his Earnest himself
[Music]
once upon a time not so long ago shoes
were just shoes and basketball shoes
were no more glamorous than any other
piece of sports equipment that was
before Michael Jordan learned how to fly
Michael Jordan is the goat
I am a huge Michael Jordan fan Jordan
another three-pointer
he defined basketball
he was that good
I don't think anything was more iconic
in the 80s than Michael Jordan
[Applause]
dominant because he was so damn good at
what he did he's only played
professional basketball a few months but
at age 21 Michael Jordan is the National
Basketball association's hottest draw
in 1984 Two Worlds Collide Michael
Jordan is a young player fresh from
college and just drafted third by the
Chicago Bulls
[Applause]
he has a lot to prove
Nike is an upstart brand determined to
take on its Rivals by any means
necessary
a total of 100 college coaches have Nike
contracts so what's the point of all of
this for Nike the exposure and that
exposure can give Nike a big boost in
its battle with long-running industry
leaders Converse and Adidas
it has become the sneaker Wars
but recruiting a new Soldier to do
battle with the competition is No Slam
Dunk Michael had never heard of Nike
they wanted to go with Adidas
I wanted him to go with Nike because I
thought that they needed him the most
that they'd be the most aggressive
promoting him
but he said David there's no way in
history I'm going to get on a plane and
fly seven hours to Portland Oregon to
meet Nike so I called his parents and
his mom said don't worry he'll be there
and sure enough he got on the plane but
he didn't crack a smile
the entire day and I thought it was
going to fire me when the day was over
but Nike was about to make an offer that
few Mortals could refuse
they offered him a signature shoe which
isn't something that was happening very
often back then unlike today where like
a lot of athletes have signature deals
back then it wasn't part of the plan
Noah the basketball player had that at
the time
to put his deal in perspective he
received the largest guarantee by far of
any player so I lead over and say to
Michael sheepishly
so what do you think I goes God this is
amazing saw me with Nike you could have
blown me away I was stunned and I
learned for the first time this guy is a
hell of a poker player
Jordan lent his name and his agent's
marketing imagination took flight
and
just instantly in my mind I got this
idea welcome to
free
[Music]
outward and the technology for their
running shoes called air souls
and I said okay we're going to call it
Air Jordan it's a double entender air
for the Air Technology and air because
Michael plays Above the Rim who says man
was not meant to fly
Air Jordans from Nike
National hype that even stood out in the
larger than life 80s
people saw a black man excelling and
people want to be like Mike so they got
his shoe
Jordans were popular on the streets but
not on the pro Court
the NBA Bandit they said it didn't
comport with the color scheme what's
wrong with the coloring what rule do we
violate here well it didn't have any
white in it
goodness well neither does the NBA
my friend Rob Strasser calls me in a
panic and said God what have we done the
league banned the shoes I said that is
fantastic and he said are you crazy I
said no no we're going to do a band in
Boston commercial tomorrow
on September 15th Nike created a
revolutionary new basketball shoe
on October 18th the NBA threw them out
of the game
fortunately the NBA can't stop you from
wearing them and it certainly worked
[Applause]
Air Jordan Nike the NBA the Chicago
Bulls and Jordan on the way to becoming
multi-billion dollar Brands Sports
revolve around statistics and our number
one seriously dunks on all the
competitions I actually have a whole
closet full of Jordans it was just the
shoe to have Michael Jordan style
Michael became so much the face of Nike
that a lot of people in the early days
called the company Mikey I think he
established that it was cool to be at
African-American athlete to be the face
of a company that was unheard of
so Michael is truly a Pioneer or want to
retire from the game with the respect of
my peers and to be
reviewed as
one of the game's best
no living breathing mere mortal human
being could deny Michael Jordan that
Legacy and Michael definitely stands
alone
[Applause]
doesn't he robbed
ha ha
[Music]
thank you